speaking of grays there is a lot to talk
about
what is in store that first episode
back how would you kind of describe it
it's it's pure madness i i gotta say
we have found a way to have really
highly concentrated
dense episodes um towards the middle of
the season
uh with a lot of this incredible
combination of loss
and joy and progress in in these
characters lives um
but but when you come back yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be
fairly uh terrifying and exhilarating
there's a lot of personal journeys and
there's um
there's a lot at stake um you know
losing
um losing your kind of grip on on
what's real and what's stable in life
and dealing with the pandemic on the
show
um i think has been really cathartic for
viewers
to feel like we don't yes there's value
in imagining elsewhere
but there's also value in like
understanding you know
a show like this is is the lan is news
for some people and i don't mean that in
that everything is a fact but is it it
is a way to get a human side to
statistics to stories and just fit
nameless you know faceless
stories these are actual people that
have loved ones that were born that have
a sister and a mom and a brother and
they're struggling with it they're not
just a stat or a demographic
um so so that's that's important you
know that's a really good point that you
bring up
and playing a first responder and
knowing what is actually happening
do you feel an added pressure to tell
these types
of stories correctly and to give people
a glimpse into what is happening
in our hospitals yeah i i do
i uh i think a lot of us do we make sure
to feel like
are we are we doing our best to
represent both the reality and a
potential future
i take it uh fairly seriously we really
examine the material and try to make
sure that we're representing
not just as many
existences in this country but examining
them with
with care and and thought
[Music]
derek we do know there's more mick
dreamy to come
how would you describe what's next from
him
on the beach will he stay on the beach i
honestly
truly don't know i don't i'm not in
those scenes and they keep that
they really did a good job of keeping
the beach stuff
away from us i think for fear of it
leaking but i know that america loves it
and i know that they'd be smart to get
as much in there as possible
and uh you know i worked with patrick
for years and uh that is one of the most
charming
people i've ever met um so i get it you
know i
i get it so i so uh we'd be lucky to
have him as much as possible
is there anyone that you would love to
see make a surprise return
like sandra oh possibly she's such a
beauty she's such an incredible actor
um yeah eric dane i had a lot of
fun fun working with um cap shaw i mean
we had
we had such great cast i really i really
enjoyed all of them
and um and uh would love to get a chance
to to work with him again
real real you know all these people
we're talking about are both incredibly
funny and incredibly uh powerful as
dramatic actors and they can switch in
and out of that
um in a way that is that is pretty
unmatched
is ellen pompeo going to be okay on the
show is there hope for meredith we know
she's entering this covid trial
and i'm a little nervous i'm a little
nervous too no there's there's
there's hope there's got to be hope i
mean uh
as far as i can see there's there's hope
and she's a she's a really hilarious
uh broad i call her because she's one of
the the last of
the broads that we have um she uh so you
know i think um
absolutely yeah i think i think there's
hope i think you know and a lot of
in a lot of ways um we've all got
a lot invested in in this and she kind
of represents both
the the sheer re the terror and the very
real
uh and reasonable fear we have of what's
kind of been washing over this country
but also our fight our our
stick-to-itiveness our preparedness
and and it really does put in
perspective you know live your life now
form your relationships now and and
people remember how you made them feel i
don't think there's anybody in tv
history that's made people feel as much
as meredith gray
that's so accurate actually people
really do
they love her she has suggested that
this could be the final season
though where do you stand i don't i
don't think so i think it i
look i i i don't know but
i think the show is too important to
go out without a damn parade you know
without us
really knowing and having a real finale
season where
these writers excuse me these writers
are so
overworked and pressed and in a rat race
to try to get
material out with without with all this
uncertainty that's not the ideal
scenario i think we
they they and all of us kind of deserve
to have the time and space to map
out um and and maybe all of that is just
a flowery way of saying i really hope
not you know yeah
is there a part of jackson's i guess
life that we haven't learned about on
the show that you would love to explore
or tell
yeah i think i'd love to
learn more about his
we tapped it in a i guess it was jpro 2
drape of the movie to his father like
this you know what it is to live without
whatever you know your dad bail on you
and or regardless of the circumstances
not without without that
that level of um parenting in your life
and what it does to you
and i think kind of completing the loop
it did feel like it you know it meant
some resolution but these are things you
know the role i learned
you know the more more therapy you're in
the more you learn that how much your
parents your parents impact you
and um you know there's a lot to unpack
there in terms of how it has impacted
his sense of identity and motivation
and um uh self-esteem
so i think there could be something
really and it was really great to work
with eric roberts
um a hell of a person and an actor i'd
love i'd love to see him and my
you know my mom i'd love to you know i'd
love i'd love to do a little more of
that because
you know out of this personal stuff as
actors you want to get on the inside
and work from the inside out and a lot
of times you know our
material reveals something that was lies
inside but it's also really fun for us
all to get
into the heart of the heart of the
matter yeah but the story lines still
excite you obviously i mean you've been
on the show forever and
yeah i feel like jackson gets pretty
good story lines
yeah i do i got no complaints i got no
complaints i'm living a hell of a life
right now
just thinking about what's to come for
the rest of the season
what are you most excited for fans to
see
in terms of what's in store for jackson
and
the show kind of as a whole
i'm most excited for fans to see
us be really brought to the brink
by what's happening in our world really
have empathy for the folks around us
that it's impacting in much harsher ways
than it might be for us
i i would love for it to be a cohesive
experience that brings us together
brings this level of um uh
understanding of for our brothers and
sisters around us and
and also showing us being able to pull
the hell out of this
thing stronger and make us
really think about what is it we want to
be doing with our lives
it ain't promised what is it you want it
how do you want your you know
your days to go yeah um and start there
i love that is there a more shocking
scene coming up than patrick dempsey's
return
oh there is okay i would think so wow
i can think you know it's all it's all
relative for who you
who you're invested in but i yeah yeah
i'd say so
i think it's sandro
fingers crossed